[Music]
what to do what to do what to do indeed
poor Christopher Robin everybody knows
Winnie the Pooh whether you know him
from a melons books or from Disney's
cartoons he's really alive as a
character and people's imaginations
however did you recognize me who ever
changed a bit yes the characters that's
my generation my parents generation and
now this generation are growing up with
your the Baron my father's drawings
Wendy the pool became a dear friend of
mine when wall gave us the assignment to
write songs for the first Winnie the
Pooh in short film and here's so many
years later it is very special to be
back in the Hundred Acre Wood well I
didn't expect to be here today there's
no doing a great job of bringing some of
their archived characters to life and as
exciting to be involved in Christopher
Robin hello everyone when a the Buddha
comes back to him and in a difficult
time in his life Christopher Robin
always comes to save us
no it's our turn to save him he speaks a
lot of truth food it would appear that I
am stuck
have you just eaten honey the whole new
generation is being introduced to this
beloved character is something very
exciting hello this is a charming story
of a man finding his home again and
finding that inner child
absolutely bare it really is a lovely
funny an adventure will come out the
better for it having seen it I think
you
[Music]